it's
6371 kilometers to the Center of the
Earth follow us down we're going all the
way to the heart of the planet
our world is made of layers a bit like
an onion and as far as we know life only
exists in the first layer the crust in
the crust you'll find the Burrows of
animals such as moles and Badgers the
deepest are made by Nile crocodiles and
can reach depths of 12 meters
the crust is also home to ancient
underground cities like elengubu in
Turkey an elaborate Labyrinth capable of
housing 20 000 people complete with
schools and chapels it is thought to
have been built around 370 Years BC
the world's deepest Minds can go down to
around four kilometers South African
gold miners have found worms two
kilometers down but all live stops
before three kilometers
then there's the deepest hole ever
drilled the cola super deep borehole in
Russia some call it the gateway to Hell
with locals claiming to hear the screams
of portrait Souls
at around 30 to 50 kilometers depth we
reach the next layer the mantle it's
made of hot rock which appears solid to
us but actually flows very slowly just a
few centimeters a year these delicate
shifts below can give rise to
earthquakes above in the 1960s a group
of scientists attempted to drill into
the Earth's mantle although unsuccessful
new efforts are a foot with a plan to
drill deep below the Indian Ocean
as we descend the increasing pressure
means that atoms become warped and even
the most familiar materials behave
bizarrely crystals change from green to
blue to Brown and rock becomes as
malleable as plastic
2 900 kilometers down we reach the
bottom of the mantle see those two giant
blobs they are the site of continents
scientists aren't sure how they were
formed or what they're made of they
cradle the next layer the outer core in
Jules Verne's classic novel Journey to
the Center of the Earth Professor utter
leidenbach encounters an entire
underground world replete with
prehistoric creatures and the
Subterranean ocean
while the dinosaurs might have been a
bit of a stretch there is an ocean of
sorts but this one consists of flowing
red hot iron and nickel a sunless sea
with its own currents and jet streams
this motion creates a magnetic field
that protects the Earth from dangerous
solar rays
the final layer is known as the inner
core
six thousand degrees in here
the pressure is so intense that the
metals here have crystallized forming a
solid sphere at the very center of our
planet
in reality our little vehicle would have
been crushed and melted long ago and as
for our driver I think she'd better head
back to the surface it's a long way to
go
good luck
thanks for watching if you enjoyed that
be sure to check out these videos next
and if you haven't already hit the
Subscribe button and click the Bell to
get a notification each time we upload a
new video